[Music]
it's only terrible to have nothing to
wait for
[Music]
it's no shame to be born stupid only to
die stupid
[Music]
life did not intend to make us perfect
whoever is perfect belongs in a museum
[Music]
strange how complicated we can make
things just to avoid showing what we
feel
[Music]
i want to think and at the same time
that's the last thing in the world i
want to do
[Music]
we have so much to say and we shall
never say it
[Music]
our knowledge of life is limited to
death
[Music]
sweet dreams though the guns are booming
no matter how improbable an assertion is
if it is made with enough assurance it
has an affect
[Music]
anything you can settle with money is
cheap
[Music]
we have our dreams because without them
we could not bear the truth
[Music]
clothes sometimes gave one more of a
lift than any philosophic comforting
[Music]
heaven has no favorites
[Music]
courage is the fairest adornment of
youth
all quiet on the western front
[Music]
what comfort there is in the skin of
someone you love
[Music]
the more primitive a man is the better
he believes himself to be
[Music]
love should not be polluted with
friendship
i am a modern man with a strong tendency
to self-destruction
[Music]
state and home country there's a
difference
the things men did or felt they had to
do
human beings are much worse poison than
schnapps or tobacco
[Music]
a man has to have something he can put
faith in
[Music]
one is sad when one thinks about life
cynical when one sees what people make
of it
good or ill life is life you only
realize that when you have to risk it
it is very clear that the unhappiness of
the world is so often brought on by
small men
[Music]
everyone saves someone at least once
just as he kills someone at least once
even though he may not know it
[Music]
keep things at arm's length if you let
anything come too near you want to hold
on to it and there is nothing a man can
hold on to
i wandered through the streets thinking
of all the things i might have said and
might have done had i been other than i
was
[Music]
to forget is the secret of eternal youth
one grows old only through memory
there's much too little forgetting
[Music]
modesty and conscientiousness receive
their reward only in novels in life they
are exploited and then shoved aside
[Music]
with blinded eyes i stared at the sky
this gray endless sky of a crazy god who
had made life and death for his
[Music]
amusement i've not much interest in the
important things of life
only in the beautiful things
just this lilac here makes me happy
[Music]
we want to live at any price so we
cannot burden ourselves with feelings
which though they might be ornamental
enough in peacetime would be out of
place here
[Music]
never do anything complicated when
something simple will serve as well
it's one of the most important secrets
of living
[Music]
you may turn into an archangel a fool or
a criminal no one will see it
but when a button is missing everyone
sees that
[Music]
but that's what mankind is like they
only prize what they no longer possess
[Music]
the main sign of an affordable woman is
her excessive sociability
[Music]
someone said to me once that a cigarette
at the right moment is better than all
the ideals in the world
[Music]
it is too dangerous for me to put these
things into words i am afraid they might
then become gigantic and i be no longer
able to master them
[Music]
i always thought everyone was against
war until i found out there are those
who are all for it especially those who
do not have to go there
[Music]
that's why they are rich of course said
i
if we were rich we certainly wouldn't be
so for long
[Music]
and without love one is a dead man on
furlough nothing but a scrap of paper
with a few dates and a chance name on it
and we as well die
[Music]
[Music]
you